Once a symbol of Beijing's goodwill.
Now the center of angry debate in China.
This panda
in Memphis, Tennessee, has become
the latest
victim in worsening US-China tensions.
Yaya arrived in America
with her playmate, Leila, two decades ago
as an emblem
of growing bilateral friendship.
But recent videos
showing the once fluffy panda
now looking
skinny with scraggly fur
has sparked outrage in China.
Many Chinese people
and some animal advocates
are accusing the zoo of mistreatment.
Just 4000
more videos on Chinese
social media claiming
the pandas are being abused quickly.
Went viral.
Against the backdrop of growing
anti-American sentiment.
The rumors are often
fanned by state propaganda
And meanwhile, Chinese social media
users are praising
these viral videos of this panda
in Russia.
Wu Yi
claiming videos of the active
and playful
panda prove
Russia is taking excellent
care of the Chinese bear.
State TV
saying the pandas are helping
the Russia
China relationship
via Chinese and American scientists
launched a joint investigation
concluding that Yaya has a genetic fur
and skin condition
that does not impact her quality of life
and has received excellent care.
But that message is not getting through.
Outside the panda
exhibit at the Beijing Zoo.
I asked people if they've heard of other
the panda firming up.
This man says,
yes, she's abused in America.
Was he's an 11 year
old boy tells me I heard the U.S.
is treating the panda poorly.
This man says, isn't Russia
taking good care of pandas?
Pandas are happy over there.
Not like in the U.S..
And this man
with his granddaughter tells me
pandas in Russia are very happy.
Why Russians and Chinese are friends.
At least Russia is not sanctioning China.
Georgia will soon settle in this
Beijing zoo.
Now, China has long used its pandas
as a diplomatic tool.
Currently,
its pandas are loaned
to about 20 countries.
The United States has not received
one since yogurt in LA 20 years ago.
Now, these pandas are normally loaned
on these ten year leases
and they cost $1,000,000 annually.
The Memphis Zoo had already planned
to send Yaya
and Lola
back to Beijing this spring
because their lease is expiring.
But Lula died of heart disease
two months ago at the age of 24.
The average lifespan for pandas
is usually under 30 years.
Yet that didn't stop rampant speculation
and led to an explosion of accusations
about yoga's treatment.
To accelerating course to bring Yahya
back to China.
The message
featured on billboards
from New York City
to major cities across China in 1972
during U.S.
President Richard Nixon's
historic trip to China.
His wife visited pandas in Beijing
on behalf
of the people of the United States.
I am pleased to be here and accept
the precious gift.
Months later,
China sent a pair of pandas
to the National Zoo in Washington, D.C..
Now, decades later,
this pandas returned from the U.S.
to China.
Symbolic not of growing friendship,
but growing animosity.
Between two global superpowers, China.